[Music]
2.4 billion women globally are not
afforded equal Economic Opportunity
in Brazil women earn an average of 30
percent less than men and many are
unbanked
[Music]
most of the people in Brazil are still
unbanked in the means of they don't have
Fair interest rates especially women the
gender inequality is immense
they don't have Fair interest rates and
access to credit like immediately and
they go to department stores to get
their credit and the Absurd interest
rates that they get is quite hard
so I saw that challenge and I told my
dad like when I grow up I would develop
that bank that will give priority to
women
my name is Dinah Hayes I'm the CEO and
founder of moyada seeds my other has
been my mission in life I see as a
legacy because my father started doing
micro credit a long time ago
my father developed one of the largest
microcredit programs for the agriculture
Farm families and I would follow him
everywhere to the cooperatives the
indigenous communities I see as well the
potential of technology to bring an idea
to its uh Financial ecosystem of social
good and greatness
[Music]
my father gave my first computer when I
was one year old and by the age of 12 I
was learning by myself many programming
languages had got to learn at a very
young age technology and how could I
help and improve people's lives
[Music]
the spark of helping women came from a
young age because I saw the challenges
that they had to overcome especially
because Brazil is a machist country a
government report found that 43 of
Brazilian women have suffered violence
in their own homes
according to un figures a woman is
assaulted every 15 seconds in Sao Paulo
but this rampant misogyny doesn't stop
at home and in the streets
women struggle for inclusion in the
financial system as well
six out of every 10 unbanked Brazilians
are women
the bank guarantees that they have are
in the name of the father into the
family so I saw the challenge especially
for women to have access to credit and a
fair interest rates I see like that
technology and help both to do
transactions for them to access capital
and people could see and trust that
their money and their Investments is
doing good
blockchain is a technology that allows
people to create trust it holds
information that is crucial for people
to measure in our case the impact
investment how many jobs we make for
each transaction and the impact on the
Environmental
we use both blockchain and artificial
intelligence to create a gamified way to
help women to access Credit with the
mentorship and the guidance we created
and develop a token that incentivizes
them along the way and by them like
hiring more women and having kpis
towards the social good and impact that
they do they can get discounts on the
interest rates and a lot of more
benefits within the network
the ecosystem moeda created allows for
people to access my way to pay
a digital account that can be used for
making payments Bank transfers and
transactions with Bitcoin and other
currency with a specialized QR code and
credit card
the MDA token was the first currency
built when moyada was formed in 2017 and
is currently the only one that can be
traded in an open market or directly
between people
the MDA token allows people from all
over the world to directly invest in my
way to seeds projects creating a global
impact
their other currencies serve varying
purposes
mdabrl is used solely within moyada's
ecosystem for people not prepared to
endure the volatility of the
cryptocurrency market
while MDA loyal rewards loyal social
impact investors with bonuses and
incentives
once the women they decide to partner
with more of the seeds we offer them
guidance and mentorship financial
education literacy and Entrepreneurship
program as well that they can take and
improve their skills and abilities and
how to develop their small and
medium-sized businesses
Lazarus would ice
five years ago talking about blockchain
technology and social impact investment
was quite challenging but today is
easier
I saw this park on their eyes and quite
early the demand of Investments with a
purpose
the impact goes among 150 000 users and
more than one million in capital
deployed along 28 beautiful projects
that we support China is in the process
of raising additional funds to expand to
over 2 000 projects in other regions in
the hope of multiplying her impact to
Millions I had many entrepreneurs from
the Latin America region they have the
same challenges within Brazil the
financial education the access to credit
they all need that while the seeds is
ready to scale and grow many times I
thought that was impossible to achieve
when you think not only about yourself
when you think about the others and how
technology can be a tool to help and
transform people's lives all the
universe can conspire for you to achieve
your goals and dreams
[Music]